it is a simple gesture small and
probably not even noticed by most
passing by but city hall in canada's
capital on this day is flying the blue
and yellow flag of ukraine
there have been protests for weeks
what's going on now is different it's no
longer about pressuring vladimir putin
and trying to prevent military action
that's happening rallies like this one
in greece are now about solidarity
there is disappointment sadness anger
fear this woman says
and worry
ukrainians everywhere share that last
one the worry
being far from home and watching from
afar is painful we need help we need
someone to support us it's our land we
didn't do anything wrong it just put in
submissions
if the emotions are there and they are
it's all just starting
explosions and the exodus are only the
beginning whether it's people huddled in
bomb shelters or fleeing the country
these stories of sadness are just the
first of many
oh just
shattered shattered not for myself not i
don't care about my safety i just i care
about ukraine
now just because a conflict starts one
way in one place doesn't mean it ends
there europeans know war has a way of
ignoring borders even if that's what's
being fought over
calling on commerce on the show more
starts this man says you don't know
where it's going to go
this chant in moscow is no to war there
are videos of russians protesting their
country's actions those videos also show
many being arrested russian authorities
realizing perhaps that if conflicts
sometimes snowball into something bigger
resistance sometimes does that as well